there are some medical news that nobody
absolutely nobody is prepared to hear I
certainly wasn't it was three years ago
that I got a call in my office with the
test results of a recent scan I was 35
and finally living the life I wanted I
married my high school sweetheart and
had finally gotten pregnant after years
of infertility and then suddenly we had
a Zack a perfect one-year-old boy
slash dinosaur depending on his mood and
having a Zack suited me perfectly I had
gotten the first job I applied for in
academia land of a thousand crushed
dreams and there I was working at my
dream job with my little baby and the
man I had imported from Canada but a few
months before I started feeling pain in
my stomach and had gone to every expert
to find out why no one could tell me and
then out of the blue
some physician's assistant called me at
work to tell me that I had stage four
cancer and that I was going to need to
come to the hospital right away and all
I could think of to say was but I have a
son I can't end this world can't end it
has just begun and then I called my
husband Danny rush to find me and I said
all the true things that I have known I
said I have loved you forever I have
loved you forever I am so sorry please
take care of our son and then as I began
to walk to the hospital they crossed my
mind for the first time
oh how ironic
I had just written a book called blessed
I'm a historian and an expert in the
idea that good things happen to good
people I research a form of Christian
and nicknamed the prosperity gospel for
it's very bold promise that God wants
you to prosper I never considered myself
a follower of the prosperity gospel
I was simply an observer the prosperity
gospel believes that God wants to reward
you if you have the right kind of faith
if you're good and faithful God will
give you health and wealth and boundless
happiness life is like a boomerang if
you're good good things will always come
back to you think positively speak
positively nothing is impossible if you
believe I got interested in this very
American theology when I was 18 or so
and by 25 I was traveling the country
interviewing its celebrities I spent a
decade talking to televangelists with
spiritual guarantees for divine money I
interviewed countless megachurch pastors
with spectacular hair about how they
live their best lives now I visited with
people in hospital waiting rooms and
plush offices I held hands with people
in wheelchairs praying to be cured I
earned my reputation as destroyer of
family vacations for always insisting on
being dropped off at the fanciest mega
church in town if there was a river
running through the sanctuary an eagle
flying freely in the auditorium or an
enormous spinning golden globe I was
there when I first started studying this
the whole idea of being blessed wasn't
what it is today
it was not like it is now an entire line
of hashtag blessed HomeGoods it was not
yet a flood of hashtag blessed vanity
license plates and t-shirts and neon
wall art I had no idea that blessed
would become one of the most common
cultural cliches one of the most used
hashtags on Instagram to celebrate
barely-there bikini
this is to say I have so blessed thank
you Jesus for this body I had not yet
fully grasped the way that the
prosperity gospel had become the great
civil religion offering another
transcendent account of the core of the
American dream
rather than worshipping the founding of
America itself the prosperity gospel
worshiped Americans it deifies and
ritualize --is their hungers their hard
work and moral fiber Americans believed
in a gospel of optimism and they are
their own proof but despite telling
myself I'm just studying the stuff I'm
nothing like them when I got my
diagnosis I suddenly understood how
deeply invested I was in my own horatio
alger theology if you live in this
culture whether you are religious or not
it is extremely difficult to avoid
falling into the trap of believing that
virtue and success go hand in hand
the more I stare down my diagnosis the
more I recognize that I had my own quiet
version of the idea that good things
happen to good people
aren't I good aren't I special somehow I
have committed zero homicides to date
why is this happening to me I wanted God
to make me good and to reward my faith
with just a few shining Awards along the
way okay like a lot of shining Awards
I believe that hardships were only
detours on what I was certain would be
my long long life as this the case of
many of us it's a mindset that served me
well the gospel of success drove me to
achieve to dream big to abandon fear it
was a mindset that served me well until
it didn't until I was confronted with
something I couldn't manage my way out
of until I found myself saying into the
phone
but I have a son because it was all I
could think of to say that was the most
difficult moment to accept the phone
call the walk to the hospital when I
realized that my own personal prosperity
gospel had failed me anything I thought
was good or special about me could not
save me my hard work my personality my
humor my perspective I had to face the
fact that my life is built with paper
walls and so is everyone else's it is a
hard thought to accept that we are all a
breath away from a problem that could
destroy something irreplaceable or alter
our lives completely
we know that in life there are befores
and afters I am asked all the time to
say that I would never go back or that
have gained so much in perspective and I
tell them no before was better a few
months after I got sick I wrote about
this and then I sent it off to an editor
at the New York Times in retrospect
taking one of the most vulnerable
moments of your life and turning it into
an op-ed is not an amazing way to feel
less vulnerable
I got thousands of letters and emails
I still get them every day I think it is
because of the questions I asked I asked
how do you live without quite so many
reasons for the bad things that happen I
asked would it be better to live without
outrageous formulas for why people
deserve what they get and what was so
funny and so terrible was of course I
thought I asked people to simmer down on
needing an explanation for the bad
things that happened so what did
thousands of readers do yeah they wrote
to defend the idea that there had to be
a reason for what happened to me and
they really want me to understand the
reason people want me to reassure them
that my cancer is all part of a plan
a few letters even suggest that it was
God's plan that I get cancer so I could
help people by writing about it people
are certain it is a test of my character
or proof of something terrible I've done
they want me to know without a doubt
that there is a hidden logic to this
seeming chaos they tell my husband while
I'm still in the hospital that
everything happens for a reason and then
stammer awkwardly when he says I'd love
to hear it
I'd love to hear the reason my wife is
dying and I get it we all want reasons
we want formulas to predict whether our
hard work will pay off whether our love
and support will always make our
partners happy and our kids love us we
want to live in a world in which not one
ounce of our hard work or our pain or
our deepest hopes will be for nothing
we want to live in a world in which
nothing is lost but what I have learned
in living with stage four cancer is that
there is no easy correlation between how
hard I try and the lengths of my life in
the last three years I've experienced
more pain and trauma than I ever thought
I could survive I realized the other day
that I've had so many abdominal
surgeries that I'm on my fifth belly
button and this last one is my least
favorite but at the same time I have
experienced love so much love love I
find hard to explain the other day I was
reading the findings of the near-death
experience Research Foundation and yes
there is such a thing people were
interviewed about their brushes with
death and all kinds of circumstances car
accidents labor and delivery suicides
and many reported the same odd thing
love I'm sure I would have ignored it if
it hadn't reminded me of something I had
experienced something I felt
uncomfortable
telling anyone that when I was sure that
I was going to die I didn't feel angry I
felt loved it was one of the most
surreal things I've experienced in a
time in which I should have felt
abandoned by God I was not reduced to
ashes I felt like I was floating
floating on the love and prayers of all
those who hummed around me like worker
bees bringing me notes and socks and
flowers and quilts embroidered with
words of encouragement but when they sat
beside me my hand in their hands my own
suffering began to feel like it had
revealed to me the suffering of others I
was entering a world of people just like
me people stumbling around in the debris
of dreams they thought they were
entitled to and plans they didn't
realize they had made it was a feeling
of being more connected somehow with
other people experiencing the same
situation and that feeling stayed with
me for months
in fact I'd grown so accustomed to it
that I started to panic at the prospect
of losing it so I began to ask friends
theologians historians nuns I liked what
am I going to do when that loving
feeling is gone and they knew exactly
what I was talking about because they'd
either experienced it themselves or
they'd read about it in great works of
Christian theology and they said yeah
it'll go the feelings will go and there
will be no formula for how to get it
back
but they offered me this little piece of
reassurance and I clung to it they said
when the feelings received like the
tides they will leave an imprint and
they do and it is not proof of anything
and it is nothing to boast about it was
just a gift so I can't respond to the
thousands of emails I get with my own
five-step plan to divine health and
magical floating feelings I see that the
world is jolted by a
that are wonderful and terrible gorgeous
and tragic
I can't reconcile the contradiction
except that I am beginning to believe
that these opposites do not cancel each
other out life is so beautiful and life
is so hard today I am doing quite well
the immunotherapy drugs appear to be
working and we are watching and waiting
with scans I hope I will live a long
time I hope I will live long enough to
embarrass my son and to watch my husband
lose his beautiful hair and I think I
might but I am learning to live and to
love without counting the cost without
reasons and assurances that nothing will
be lost
life will break your heart and life may
take everything you have and everything
you hope for but there is one kind of
prosperity gospel that I believe in I
believe that in the darkness even there
there will be beauty and there will be
love and every now and then it will feel
like more than enough thank you
[Applause]